una doctrina contra El dominio de
occidente y para defender el mundo ruso
el presidente Vladimir Putin dio a
conocer su nueva estrategia de política
exterior
Moscú se apoya en China e India como
principales aliados para hacer frente a
lo que denomina como amenazas
existenciales
la justicia sudafricana rechazó el
pedido de prisión condicional para el ex
atleta Oscar pistorios Quien fuera una
afamada estrella deportiva permanecerá
entre rejas cumpliendo su condena por
haber asesinado a su pareja hace ya 10
años abordamos este mediático caso en
nuestro estudio
hoy se conmemora el Día Internacional de
la visibilidad transgénero la fecha
tiene como objetivo combatir crear
conciencia y sensibilizar sobre la
discriminación que las personas trans
sufren en todo el mundo les traemos
análisis
nueva emisión informativa en la pantalla
de France 24 gracias por elegirnos mi
nombre es Juan pupiales
damos inicio a esta emisión en Rusia
porque el presidente Vladimir Putin
firmó su nueva estrategia de política
exterior se trata de una política
cimentada en la visión de que occidente
representa una amenaza para
Moscú el texto habla de dar prioridad a
Rusia para eliminar lo que denominan
como vestigios del dominio de Estados
Unidos y otros países no amistosos en el
mundo político
Moscú identifica a China India como
aliados para el futuro y habla de
amenazas existenciales por parte de
occidente de refuerza la idea de un
mundo ruso un argumento bajo el cual ha
justificado acciones en Ucrania en favor
aseguran de la comunidad rusoparlante
excepto de política exterior suponen que
las medidas antirrusas de Estados
hostiles serán consistentemente y si es
necesario severamente suprimidas se
establece claramente la idea de que no
nos estamos aislando de los países
anglosajones y de la Europa occidental
no tenemos intenciones fundamentalmente
hostiles hacia ellos sin embargo deben
ser conscientes de que la cooperación
pragmática con Rusia sólo es posible si
se dan cuenta de la inutilidad de una
política de confrontación
hace un año las tropas rusas se vieron
forzadas a abandonar la ciudad de bucha
cerca de kiev dejando atrás de ellos una
huella de muerte y destrucción 12 meses
después el presidente de ucraniano
boladimir varios representantes de
países de Europa del este visitaron la
urbe mientras sus residentes siguen
intentando recuperarse y reconstruir sus
hogares más en el siguiente informe
[Aplausos]
pasó un año desde la liberación de bucha
el escenario de algunas de las peores
atrocidades cometidas por el ejército
Ruso y epicentro de las denuncias de
crímenes de guerra el presidente
ucraniano recordó las masacres cometidas
por los rusos contra los civiles
en las calles de hucha el mundo vio el
mal ruso el mal sin disfraz vio lo que
el kremlin pretendía llevar a otras
calles de Ucrania de Europa y del mundo
que podrían ser tomadas por Los
Invasores rusos podrían si no fuera por
nosotros si no fuera por los ucranianos
después de La retirada rusa las fuerzas
ucranianas se encontraron los cuerpos de
civiles asesinados en una calle algunos
con las manos atadas a la espalda y
llegaron los hallazgos que espantaron a
la comunidad internacional cuando se
descubrieron fosas comunes con cientos
de cuerpos enterrados barrios con signos
de torturados según selensky la
ocupación rusa de la ciudad resultó en
más de 1.400 muertes incluidos 37 niños
y se han identificado nueve mil crímenes
de guerra rusos hoy los residentes de
este sitio que fue escenario del terror
están tratando de superar el pasado pero
los recuerdos aún están frescos en su
mente incluso para los más jóvenes
[Música]
un año después bucha ha entrado en una
nueva fase una de reconstrucción con la
esperanza de que esto ayude a cerrar un
capítulo doloroso Los investigadores
internacionales siguen recogiendo
pruebas en bucha y en otras ciudades
donde las tropas rusas hubieran cometido
atrocidades a gran escala
el ex atleta paralímpico Oscar pistorios
tendrá que permanecer al menos un año y
cuatro meses más en prisión luego de que
la junta de libertad condicional que
analizó su caso le negara el beneficio
de Libertad bajo palabra la junta
Consideró que todavía es visto no ha
cumplido la mitad de la pena impuesta
por el homicidio de su novia la modelo
riva stingham el corredor sudafricano y
su historia en Londres en 2012 al ser el
primer paralímpico que corría contra
atletas convencionales pero 7 meses
después fue detenido por el asesinato de
su pareja el atleta fue sentenciado a 13
años en 2016 para analizar este caso
está con nosotros una de nuestras
cronistas deportivas Omar esa Gracias
por estar con nosotros eumar estamos
hablando de la historia de un héroe que
cayó en desgracia si un héroe que pasó
De héroe Villano en apenas seis meses
pistores recordemos fue el primer gran
Astro del deporte paralímpico
básicamente por su lucha para competir
contra atletas convencionales que
incluso lo llevó a enfrentarse a la
antiguaya Félix en el tribunal de
arbitraje del deporte
intentó participar en Beijing 2008 pero
la antigua iaf lo declaró no elegible
con base en un estudio científico que
decía que su prótesis de fibra de
carbono le daban ventaja Porque después
de la salida corría de forma más
eficiente que un atleta convencional lo
que implicaba menor desgaste para
alcanzar la velocidad máxima pistorios
recorrió ante el Tas basado en un
informe de un experto en biomecánica
también doblo amputado un antiguo
montañista que mostraba que tanto su
consumo energético como su Rango de
fatiga eran iguales a los de los atletas
convencionales eso revirtió la decisión
de la iaf y le permitió participar en
Londres 2012 a donde clasificó con una
marca de 45 07 para que se dé una idea
el récord Nacional de mi país de
Venezuela es 45 21 de manera que corrió
más rápido que eso que un atleta
convencional un atleta que fue
considerado como ejemplo que súbitamente
mostró su cara más oscura de aficionado
a las armas y de obsesionado con los
temas de seguridad el mar estamos
hablando de un caso en el que ha habido
una enorme presión Por parte sobre todo
de la familia de arriba es incap para
que episodios no goce de este beneficio
y cumpla toda su condena en prisión si
recordemos que la decisión inicial en
2014 fue declararlo culpable de
homicidio culposo condenarlo a cinco
años de prisión y luego Esto fue
conmutado por arresto domiciliario en
2015 la corte de apelaciones cambia la
calificación del delito con el argumento
de que pistorius tenía intenciones de
matar fuera a su novia o a un intruso
que era lo que él argumentaba la versión
que sostuvo siempre se rejuga Entonces
por asesinatos se le condena a seis años
pero la fiscalía por supuesto a
instancias de la familia de Rivas tinka
recurre y en 2017 la Corte Suprema dobla
la pena a 13 años en junio del año
pasado pistorius participó junto al
padre de arriba en una audiencia
conocida como diálogo víctima agresor
que es parte del sistema sudafricano de
justicia a la que tiene derecho para
poder solicitar la Libertad bajo palabra
lo hizo pero ahora a pesar de que
cumplió con ese requisito Ahora tiene
que esperar hasta agosto de 2024 para
poder aspirar de nuevo al beneficio la
familia de episodios la familia de
arriba se llama que asegura que no ha
habido remordimiento por parte de
episodios Omar como siempre Muchísimas
gracias nosotros vamos a cambiar de tema
porque como cada 31 de marzo hoy se
conmemora el Día Internacional de la
visibilidad transgenera una fecha que
tiene como objetivo visibilizar la
discriminación que las personas trans
sufren en todo el mundo para abordar ese
tema nos acompaña Alex Castillo
presidente de la red latinoamericana de
hombres trans hablemos señor Alex
primero que todo gracias por estar con
nosotros de un problema clave que
atraviesa y marca la existencia de las
personas trans el no reconocimiento de
la identidad de género que ocurre en
muchos países
Hola buenos días un gusto estar con
ustedes pues
sí efectivamente ha dicho la mayor
violencia que sufrimos las personas
trans es la no identidad de género el no
respeto a a esta identidad que nos
niegan a través de leyes porque a través
del no reconocernos como personas trans
automáticamente se vuelve
una continuidad de violación a tu
derecho porque no tienes derecho a
saludar trabajo empleo a familia en fin
desde ahí se desencadena no
reconocimiento de que estamos existimos
y sobre todo resistimos en resiliencia
en esta sociedad particularmente creo
Usted que hay una invisibilización de
los varones trans
Bueno si eso ha sido una cuestión que
que ha surgido históricamente creo que
los varones trans como fuimos somos
hijos del patriarcado también donde se
nos no se nos permitía cuestionar hablar
sino simple y sencillamente naturalizar
la violencia creo que esto nos hizo
estar en silencio durante muchísimos
años pero creo que hemos logrado ir
rompiendo poco a poco todo ese
patriarcado que hemos tenido encima y
hemos empezado a Elevar nuestras voces y
sobre todo hablar sobre nuestras propias
necesidades y las violencias que hemos
sufrido desde el momento que fuimos
asignados femeninos al nacer hay una
práctica de la que son víctimas las
personas trans y que horroriza las
denominadas violaciones correctivas
podría contarnos En qué consisten por
favor
Bueno quiero comentarte que en Guatemala
específicamente hicimos un estudio de
hombres trans donde el 80% de los
encuestados hablaron de haber sufrido
violaciones correctivas qué es lo que
sucede simple y sencillamente que como
fuiste asignado femenino al nacer tienes
que tener esa violencia sexual en tu
cuerpo para que realmente te des cuenta
que fuiste asignado femenino y por lo
tanto tienes que cumplir el rol de
procrear de engendrar de dar
fruto a la vida y eso es como muy común
y es donde los varones trans Muchas
veces tenemos que detener nuestra
transición porque obviamente
gestamos y al gestar pues vamos a tener
hijos hijas e hijas de quienes van a
depender económicamente de nosotros
es Castillo gracias por este relato esta
información en este día para visibilizar
a la comunidad trans cambiamos de tema
el gobierno italiano se convirtió este
viernes en el primer país en suspender
temporalmente el chat gpt de
Inteligencia artificial alegando
preocupaciones de privacidad según la
autoridad de protección de datos del
país la firma estadounidense Open no
tiene base legal para justificar la
recolección y almacenamiento masivo de
datos personales bajo el propósito de
entrenar al algoritmo que permite el
funcionamiento de su plataforma ya
algunas universidades en el mundo han
prohibido este chat por miedo a que
pueda ser usado por los estudiantes en
sus labores de momento Open ella y no ha
comentado la decisión
la presidenta de Taiwán Da inicio este
viernes a su gira por Centroamérica
luego de haber viajado a Estados Unidos
este viernes llega a Guatemala con la
intención de firmar acuerdos bilaterales
con este país y Belice 12 de los últimos
13 países que aún reconocen al gobierno
de La Isla frente a Beijing nuestra
corresponsal en Centroamérica Aurora
wayú nos amplía desde Guatemala
se tratará de realzar Los lazos
diplomáticos con los pocos aliados que
le quedan la presidente de Taiwán inicia
este viernes una visita oficial a
Guatemala y Belice en estar acompañada
su canciller quien declaró en su cuenta
de Twitter que ya la habían avisado de
que en ambas naciones tanto la gente
como el clima eran calurosos pero el
objetivo de Esta visita trasciende el
solo turismo efectivamente desde hace
unos años Guatemala y Taiwán vienen
consolidando una relación de cooperación
sobre todo desde la pandemia cuando
Taiwán fue el primero en ayudar a
Guatemala con donaciones de equipos
contra el covid 19 de hecho está
previsto que este fin de semana la
presidental ahí visité aquí en Guatemala
el hospital de Chimaltenango una obra
que contó con el apoyo financiero de
Taiwán y que está considerada por
Alejandro yamate y el presidente de
Guatemala como el hospital más grande de
Centroamérica el gobierno de Guatemala
viene manifestando ante la comunidad
internacional su compromiso para velar
por la soberanía de La Isla frente a
Beijing quien considera a Taiwán como
parte de su territorio pero esta visita
de la presidenta de Taiwán interviene en
un momento crítico para la isla después
de que la presidenta de Honduras sea
omara Castro anunciará a abandonar sus
relaciones con Taiwán para
restablecerlas con Beijing actualmente
13 estado siguen manteniendo relaciones
con la isla incluyendo Belice donde la
presidenta de Taiwán tiene previsto
reunirse con el Primer Ministro John
briceño
la respuesta de China llegó de la mano
de su cancillería el gigante asiático
dice que espera que Guatemala tome la
decisión correcta y habló de una
tendencia general a la hora de reconocer
la política de una sola china recordemos
que la semana pasado a Honduras país
vecino de Guatemala rompió sus lazos con
taipei y estableció relaciones con
Beijing
después del establecimiento de lazos
diplomáticos entre China y Honduras 182
países en el mundo ahora han establecido
lazos diplomáticos con china esto
demuestra plenamente que el principio de
una china es el interés general del
mundo la aspiración común de la gente y
la tendencia de los tiempos que ninguna
fuerza puede detener apoyar la
independencia de Taiwán y las
actividades secesionistas va en contra
de la voluntad y los intereses de la
nación China y en contra de la tendencia
de la historia es un callejón sin salida
Esperamos que Guatemala entienda
claramente esta tendencia y que tome la
decisión correcta en una fecha temprana
estamos bien así a esta emisión la
invitación es a ustedes para que sigan
conectados con nuestra señal y con
nuestros informativos y también con
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]